88 avec Alexandra Sublet
de Céline Dion
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
dans le système judiciaire les crimes
sexuels sont considérés comme
particulièrement monstrueux à New York
les inspecteurs qui enquêtent sur ces
crimes sont membres d'une unité d'élite
appelée unité spéciale pour les victimes
voici leurs histoires
ce filtre il est incroyable je regardais
je suis chez moi et là ça me fait un
labyrinthe attends là ma famille est
littéralement en train de me voir
tourner dans mon jardin là
je prends la petite porte sur la petite
porte
attends là
on n'en sort jamais de ce truc
faut que tu acceptes les conséquences et
qu'on met quand mes compétences ne font
que augmenter tu bouges la tête le son
te lance la concurrence Clément Clément
je dois rester concentré je dépense de
longues séances l'essence du sang
soupçon de chance simplement contenter
mais avec élégance toujours en avance et
toute la France viendra me contempler et
voilà fin de la teinture blonde que
j'avais faite pour OS
retour au brun naturel
retour à la normalité un kiff